I'm Noelle I spent roughly 10 years as a
data scientist before I transitioned
into a roll with product as Scott had
mentioned because I was trying to see if
I could prevent a lot of the data
problems that a lot of us see every day
before they actually happen so in my
experience I've lived through many bad
and some really good attempts at
including data scientists and data
Engineers into app Dev team workflows
as you're trying to build products that
have ai in them and I've done this at
several companies both at large large
Enterprises working in-house as well as
a consultant where I worked with
everyone from startups into the Fortune
500 and I hope you leave here today with
some strategies on how not to repeat
some of these mistakes
and today by the way I'm going to use AI
as an umbrella term to cover AI machine
learning data science
Etc
so if you like to skip the to the how-to
part of this talk it is simply this if
you want to be successful you putting AI
into your products please involve your
data people early please bring your data
scientist and your data engineer into
your cross-functional conversations with
product with design with engineering do
it frequently do it early
and that's pretty much it that's the
secret
all right we're done thank you very much
you all have been a great audience
wow that joke did not land
told you I should have taken it out
well now that that's out there I want to
spend the rest of time that we have
together today talking through some of
my hot takes around
how you build products with AI that
cross-functional collaboration and what
happens when it goes all wrong those
tragic mistakes and then what happens
next
companies
this sounds familiar doesn't it so
companies all have different paths to
using Ai and when I was a data science
consultant I would frequently have
clients who would ask me if we could
just add a little AI to the product and
they viewed it as something that I could
just
sprinkle on at the end on top of their
product and it was something that would
make their product cooler and more
appealing and shiny but they didn't
include how AI was actually strategic to
their company Vision if AI was actually
solving anything or any problems that
they had or even if they were data
driven to begin with and what I learned
is that a lot of these companies a lot
of these people fundamentally do not
understand what AI is they don't
understand all the things that it takes
to build it
and then ultimately when that happens
when they're in the room making those
decisions up front they'll vastly
underestimate what it takes to build it
and the people who do know that the data
scientists data Engineers the data team
they're not invited to those early
scoping calls they're not invited to
those early conversations
so there are a few problems with asking
questions like this that I'd like to
point out
so here come the hot takes that's what
you're all here for
first hot take your data is way more
important than any AI that you build
so this is a talk about AI I know that
but I would be remiss if I didn't spend
a minute to call out how important the
data is in and of itself and not just
because it is a prerequisite for AI
which we'll get to in a minute
but because data itself is a
prerequisite for measuring success and
for understanding your business and many
many companies don't even do that they
don't use their data effectively to run
their businesses it is far more
important for you to have a
well-instrumented product that generates
all of the data that you'll need for
running a data driven organization
than any one specific killer AI feature
that you're going to build so that
includes your Downstream metrics your
dashboards things you need for
operational operations and yes of course
AI
so usually our priority should be asking
about your data long before you're
asking about whether or not you should
be building AI
[Music]
so it's still shocking to me that
there's a lot of companies that don't
even have this basic instrumentation in
place so immediately after your product
is released your Executives and all the
stakeholders will start asking questions
like hey is our product successful is
anybody using it what are our most
valuable customers doing on the product
and it turns out that no one can
actually answer that if no one thought
about instrumenting your product in the
first place
so I cannot stress enough how important
it is to take care of your data before
you attempt to even do AI
but even though I said that doesn't mean
that people don't try
they try all the time and tragically
I've seen companies who reach straight
for AI before even evaluating where they
are with their data and their metrics
but if your company doesn't do data or
metrics well it's unlikely you're going
to be successful implementing AI so in
addition to the quality of the AI being
dependent on the quality of the data
that you're feeding it the success of
your AI is also dependent on the
framework and strategy your company has
with dealing and working with data
so even if you're a data scientist and
you work in one of these organizations
you say I'm gonna I'm gonna do it anyway
I'm gonna build a model and you're able
to create a really great model problem
is building a great model the model
itself isn't enough and I think that's
the lie that all data scientists myself
included believe at some point in their
careers that all you need to do to be
successful is build a great model killer
model that's it
so far from the truth because Success is
Not defined in a vacuum ultimately the
point of AI is you want it to be
repeatable you want it to be put into a
product that's what success looks like
but in order to do that it requires way
more than just building it in a box it
requires thinking about the ongoing data
generation the pipelines the feedback
loops all of these things
it's a lot of work so it brings me back
to the question hey can you just add a
little AI to the product
no no you cannot just add a little AI to
the product
a few reasons why so someone saying some
Executives saying hey we're going to add
AI by itself is not a strategic plan it
really isn't and so unless you have data
to show why it's adding business value
to what you're doing to your end users
your internal teams you shouldn't do it
unless you know what you're doing
and then the expectation that just
adding a little AI or adding anything
data related is not the reality of it
despite what you may what targeted ads
may say despite what some of the pitches
may say it's not as simple as putting
getting something out of the box being
hands-off and getting a magical solution
forever you can't just get AI for free
you can't just get robust data for free
you can't just get your success metrics
for free it's a lot more involved to it
and broadly speaking adding features
that have ai that surface something that
AI is generating somewhere isn't the
same scale of effort as adding something
that's in your typical Sprint backlog
all right so again even though people
shouldn't do this they do anyway which
brings me to a tragic mistake
which is not involving your data people
at all
so the assumption that you could just
add a little AI to your product usually
also comes with the assumption that all
data and AI related things can be done
whatever and by whomever
but that's just not true so I've seen
companies who say they want to build a
smart app or an AI app from the
beginning end up saying you know what we
can we don't need that yet we're going
to push all of that data stuff
Downstream including the data
instrumentation so some for some future
undetermined release
is when they'll do it and so because of
that they just never call the data team
they never call data scientist or
engineer to talk about it and when you
do go down that route you're likely
exchanging a simpler product up front
for a lot of data technical debt
Downstream and that not only affects the
AI that you're building with things like
product experimentation business
reporting and so on
in other instances I seen the dev team
being asked to take on all of the data
tasks as well and devs are smart
brilliant people they're very capable
and a lot of them have taken machine
learning and statistics in school but
it's unfair to ask them to take on ex
all that extra work to wear Three Hats
as the data scientist and the data
engineer as well and in my experience
when they eventually have to hand over
that work to the data team it ends up
being redone anyway and it's tragic not
including the data scientists and the
data engineers
to do the data work because that's what
they're hired and trained and have
expertise to do
speaking of data scientists and data
Engineers let's get into some specifics
about what it is they do I guess Monica
rogati is a popular shout out today but
this I don't know if everyone has seen
this before the AI hierarchy of needs
from an article by Monica rogadian on um
Hacker News one of my favorite charts I
highly recommend you go read the article
and so you'll see here that AI at the
top which gets all the hype and
attention ultimately cannot be done
without all of the tiers below it in
this diagram and if you remember the Hot
take from a few slides ago you'll see
that even in this diagram data comes way
before AI you need data you need the
infrastructure you need metrics and
analytics which are important in and of
themselves as well as for use in AI
and data engineering tends to work on
the bottom half of this pyramid and I'd
say that data scientists tend to work on
the top half of this pyramid there's a
bunch of overlap in the middle of course
yeah in the explore transform layer
especially
and as you read through this chart
you'll look you'll see things that look
very engineering like infrastructure and
pipelines and you'll also see things
that look very businessy uh like
segmentation and metrics and those are
very useful in making product or design
decisions
so this whole pyramid doesn't entirely
fall under another function like
engineering or product and instead has a
little bit of everything it means though
that there's a lot of places where the
collaboration can happen remember the
cross collaboration I talked about
earlier today
there's lots of there's you can see
already where the topics were that would
happen but in order to take advantage of
that Synergy between those teens we have
to actively plan the collaboration just
doesn't happen on its own so you need to
decide a few things you need to decide
who what and when
so who exactly is talking together well
at the start of this talk I said the key
was bringing data scientists and data
engineer who else said we should bring
in the product manager bring in the
engineers who are specifically working
on the parts of the product that are
touching the AI as well as the data
instrumentation piece and bring in the
designer all of these people are making
decisions that affect the data and that
in turn affects the AI which then
affects the end product you're all
trying to create
you bring all of those people together
what is it that you're talking about a
few things one let's talk about what is
AI expected to do in your product are
you expecting it to spit out a
recommendation a number a pitcher
that's the whole story what is it
um and being by doing this you're
allowing your data scientists to discern
what models you might most need to want
to try what would be appropriate what
data will you need what tools will you
need
to build it
and in addition to that so we mentioned
talking about the data so what data will
be generated from this product
in addition to the AI all of those other
teams also will be looking at data your
engineering team your product team Your
Design they all want to look at metrics
you should consider all of those things
together when you're instrumenting your
product
and finally you should consider how that
data is getting generated and how will
it get from place to place
how does it get from the product into
the AI
spit out results and back in any
feedback loops and especially while you
have all of those Engineers together you
can really de-risk some things that way
okay so now we have the who the what the
question now is when this team should
talk so time for another hot take
it is never too early to talk but it is
often too late honestly most of the
preventive preventable mistakes that
I've seen happen too late because
or if they even happen at all when they
bring in the data people and the best
time to kick off this conversation with
the team is during early development so
depending on how your organization
builds products this could be during the
PRD writing process the design process
MVP pilot and so on
if you bring your data people into the
conversation early it gives them the
opportunity to set themselves and
everybody else up for Success Downstream
they help design the data that they
later ingest and model they right size
the expectations of the AI they can
highlight all of the data dependencies
it also provides you an opportunity to
instrument the product once up front so
you could have a single source of truth
about what's happening in the product
that all the teams who are looking at
data and use and using it to make data
driven decisions are working on the same
understanding so of course the data
product engineering design team but also
think about Marketing sales operations
Finance everyone in your organization
who wants to understand what's going on
with your product could look at one
source of Truth
for me the opposite of a product that
has absolutely no data instrumentation
where everybody is Flying Blind is a
product that has been instrumented
multiple times by different teams so you
have
different data sets and it turns out
that none of the metrics exactly added
line up with each other and no one is
working on the same source of truth that
is chaotic and very painful
so in addition to de-risking the data
you can also de-risk the AI so that
could be knowing what AI is feasible
given what you have at the time given
the data that you have but also what
you're constrained by technically
mathematically legally ethically and
also what you may be able to do in the
future we might not have the data yet
but you could
in addition to that there's also a
negotiation between what you might want
to build like oh I can make a super
super cool model that's super accurate
but maybe it will take too long to
develop maybe it's too expensive to run
maybe you could maybe there's an
alternative of something that's maybe
not as accurate but may be sufficient
but that's a negotiation that you can
have up front and at a time
so what happens if you don't have your
data scientists and data engineer helped
you risk your products well
remember the hierarchy of needs that we
talked about earlier you may end up not
having the necessary foundation for AI
so even if you have executive buy-in you
have a really great business use case
everyone great data scientists you're
looking forward to making AI
if the data wasn't taken care of much
earlier in the process you may stumble
you may find that the data doesn't
support the AI that you want to build
just doesn't exist
or the instrumentation doesn't exist at
all or it turns out you have data but it
was instrumented by some person several
years ago who's left the company didn't
document anything and no one knows how
it's defined there's no record of it or
the data is messy it's incomplete it's
truncated it's way too aggregate to
support your AI all of these things
could make you stumble
and unfortunately you can't build any AI
until you fix this problem until you fix
until you fix your data immense rotation
you can't move forward and then surprise
after you fix the instrumentation then
you got to wait for the data to actually
be generated you had to wait for having
enough data to then build your AI and
since no one has a time machine that I
know of or a Time Stone it's going to
take a while until AI is going to be
possible
okay so we talked about when as being
early
but we when can also be about how
frequent
and for this last hot take
say you've managed to Wrangle everyone
together
early for the development life cycle but
one conversation does not a
collaboration make remember that this
needs to be an ongoing collaboration in
order to be successful teams that come
together once but then go back into
their silos we'll have a lot of
difficulty staying in sync
there's many ways that you can
collaborate the key is really just to do
it frequently and consistently
my personal preference is to add data
scientists and data Engineers to
pre-existing meetings and then only add
additional meetings if you have
special topics come up to in order to
limit the overall meeting burden that we
all have
and to give you some examples some if
your team follows scrum a great place to
do this is to add data people to your
Sprint planning or to your demos
and in Sprint planning you could take
advantage of having your data people in
the room by considering things like hey
if you're looking at all these stories
in the backlog are any of them actually
dependent on a data story is that data
work actually completed yet are we
blocked here how big does that work or
do any of the stories in the backlog
result in new data being generated will
that eventually potentially affect the
AI is anybody testing it maybe we should
another place that we can add
data people is to invite them to your
demos invite them to both learn what the
product is that they're helping build as
well as the work that they're doing on
AI and the data pipelines and the added
context and the feedback you get from
that is so valuable across the team I
encourage you to share your progress
before things aren't complete and
Polished share them with their
incomplete and unpolished and I imagine
at most companies regular Cadence
communication looks somewhere like
somewhere between monthly and weekly
just depending on how your team is and
what stage of the development that
you're in
huh
and for this last tragic mistake let's
imagine if we built products by having
one big meeting if to review a prdr
Specs assigning every individual person
to their work and then telling them to
go work in a silo in isolation by
themselves for three months and then
come back together and try and piece and
everything all together and see if it
works that would be a disaster right
yeah
but that's effectively what I've seen
happen in organizations with AI they
draw a line in the product up front they
say this work over here is the AI this
work over here is the core product and
then the teams never collaborate or
communicate after that and while like I
acknowledge that building these
components are very different things
it's really important to regularly check
in to assure that one you're still
working towards the same product vision
two that you're testing all of the
pieces that are supposed to work
together as you're building them instead
of waiting for all of that integration
in the end
and when organizations wait until the
very end to piece things together
sometimes the fit between the AI and the
product is so bad that they just scrap
the aips but you know what this was a
bad idea we're not going to do it we'll
just go with the core product because we
need to launch it right and maybe
they'll come back to the AI at a future
iteration maybe they just abandon it all
together either way it's extremely
disheartening when that happens and
what's even more tragic is if that
includes a lot of the data
instrumentation pieces you lose the
ability to measure and learn because
that part was taken away as well
so I've mentioned early several times
today but let's say you're in a
situation where early has passed you by
the product is built in live you're in a
situation where you have decent data and
you decide I want to move forward with
AI
can you still use AI can you still add
AI to a product
well the short answer is yes
yes but the collective team will still
face a lot of struggles getting AI into
the product so in addition to all the
communication pieces we talked about
earlier
they're they're Pro there will still be
technical issues with this the what you
can build with AI at the time might be
different than what you would want to do
if you had been called in earlier
um the fit between the pieces may feel
clunky and inefficient because of the
order that things were ultimately built
and when the product changes or anything
causes the data to look different things
can break without anyone understanding
where they happened or why it's
happening and it'll take a long time to
debug
and I'm not saying that this is
impossible you can do this but it takes
a PM with a very bold Vision that
includes Ai and has persistence to work
through the technical challenge you'll
likely have
so to recap the journey today for hot
takes one your data is more important
than AI
no you cannot just add a little AI
it's never too early to include your
data scientist and your data engineer
into your workflow in a single
conversation is not a collaboration
and if you're still not sure if you're
ready to put AI in your product you can
easily avoid some of the tragic mistakes
I talked about today by ensuring that at
the very least you have data that exists
that you have a data scientist and a
data engineer who will work with your
team but also people who have data
fluency in your organization and
especially a compelling business reason
for using AI
and the last thing I'd like to leave you
with is some guidelines for making your
own collaboration framework for whatever
that looks like at your company
round up all the people that you know
that you need to make AI in your product
successful
get them talking to each other as early
as you can in the workflow and establish
a Cadence for bringing this team
together from the start
through the release
and with that that was the end I wish
you all the very best in your AI
Endeavors thank you so much for allowing
me the time to share my experiences with
you today feel free to reach out to me
or come to the office hour that
immediately follows after this and enjoy
the rest of the conference and
specifically this track that has a lot
of real cool success stories of people
who have used and their products thank
you
thank you